Hey guys, I hope everyone's doing well.
Hope we've all had a very nice holiday
week. So, the reason for me making this
video is twofold. The first is that I am
too lazy to make a systems design video
this week, mainly because I'm actually
making this like 11 days before I post
it. I don't have time to get another one
off before I run off to New York for the
holidays. But more importantly, I would
love to review the past year a little
bit and then maybe
offer some words of inspiration or
motivation for next year. Now, I
certainly am no inspirational speaker.
At the end of the day, I love sitting on
my ass a lot too and doing nothing.
But
me and some of the viewers of this
channel
have shared some lovely moments of
inspiration and grinding speech and so
I'll contribute my little bit once more.
So,
just looking back on 2023, this was a
really really amazing year both for
myself personally in terms of growth
socially. Moved to another city where I
didn't really know anyone and I feel
like I'm finally getting to the point
where I actually have a bit of a friend
group going, which is really amazing.
And then in addition to that for the
channel, I think we probably doubled in
size this year in terms of subscriber
growth, which is really cool.
Again, that's really not the main thing
that I care about when it comes to
posting here. Right now, I'm a lot more
concerned with how many people I'm
actually helping. So, you know, it makes
me a lot more happy to see someone else
say they got a job through watching
these videos
than it does to increase my subscriber
count. I'm not really trying that hard
to make money on this thing, at least
not for the time being. I care a lot
more about just helping people. And so
far, it seems I've been able to have
some moderate impact doing that, which
is really great. Anyways, besides the
viewers who I have had the privilege of
assisting in their job search, I know
there's still plenty of you that are
still on the path and making good
progress there. And for those of you, I
will say, you know, it's a new year, but
it shouldn't be a new you, right? At the
same time, you've um
been spending all this time already,
devoting all this effort to getting
really good at systems design or
interview prep or whatever it may be. It
doesn't even have to necessarily be
anything to do with coding or your job
whatsoever. But I guess the idea is
that, you know, it's a new year, but you
just want to stay as consistent as you
have been and the results will show.
They always do. And that's going to be
the case whether it's coding or in my
case whether it's bodybuilding or, you
know, if it's just making new friends or
anything like that, it always applies.
And so, you know, as some parting
advice, I guess to make one
macroeconomic observation, even though
I'm no economist by any means, it
definitely does seem like things are
starting to pick back up a little bit.
The stock market's been going up. My net
worth has gone up ever so slightly. And
in addition to that, I think that the
jobs from big tech companies is probably
going to be a lagging indicator. But
whenever they do pick back up and it
does seem like it'll probably end up
being maybe later this year at some
point, I think there's a good chance
that if you're the first one who's fully
prepared to interview, you're going to
have a lot better of a shot of getting a
job than everyone else who only waits to
start prepping once they realize that
the job market is heating back up. Right
now, if I look on Blind or I look on
Reddit, I see a lot of people who just
say very blatantly that they just want
to stay in their current position and
there's nothing wrong with that. But if
you do know that you're eventually going
to want to switch within the next year
or so, I think that now is a really good
time to start prepping. Now, obviously,
this message is self-serving. I'm
running a systems design YouTube
channel, but at the same time, I do
genuinely believe that if you think,
"Hey, there's a good chance that I try
and job hop later in this year."
Well,
at the end of the day, now is the best
time to get started because you know,
when those job listings get posted, you
want to be right on top of them and you
want to be ready to beat those
interviews.
So guys, that's really all I'm going to
leave you with today. I just wanted to
make sure to post something quickly
because at the end of the day, I I view
this channel as as something that's very
important to me and it's important to me
that I make some sort of timely post to
it whether it's a systems design video
or not. But of course, as always, have a
great week. Enjoy your new year and I'm
looking forward to all the amazing
things that we can do in 2024. Peace and
I'll see you soon.